this year marks 75 since the end of
world war
ii where more than 16 million americans
served in that war
now a new book offers fresh insight into
what life was like on the front lines
through a series of letters written
by a young soldier the detailed notes in
dear selma
allow readers to experience the
day-to-day struggles and triumphs of
american troops in europe
and as chip reid shows us the letters
had a lasting impact
on the lives they touched
that's bernard brown now
96 years old was just 19 when he was
drafted into the army
during world war ii
longing for connection back home he
started writing
to a childhood friend named selma
just four months after d-day
[Music]
brown's unit boarded a ship to europe
his frequent letters to selma
paint a vivid picture of the sacrifice
of american forces
on the front lines after spending four
nights and three days
in the mud sleeping eating and trying to
fight
he describes living in a foxhole in the
thick of battle in france
and the haunting image of the gaunt
jewish prisoners
his unit helped liberate from the dachau
concentration camp
but amid the chaos of war the letters
gradually
became a declaration of love
i really liked this person just made me
feel good every time i read her letters
and i thought you know i've got to know
her better i just have to know her
better
you got pretty pretty sappy there at
some point
yes yeah i was eager if you only knew
how much i want to come back
so that you and i can start living our
life together
and after the germans surrendered in
1945
brown did just that marrying selma
three months after he returned home
eventually
they had three children and later five
grandchildren
they were married for 72 years before
selma passed away
in 2017. as his family prepared to move
him into a portland retirement facility
his daughter shelly came across a dusty
old box
it was probably around 600 pages of
handwritten letters
we would call dad up and say tell us
about
this what did that mean and then the
kind of memories that were coming
out of his mind were incredible
although brown earned a bronze star and
a purple heart
he rarely shared stories of his time
overseas
when you read these letters that you had
written so many years before did they
bring tears to your eyes
they did they brought a lot of memories
to me how important
is it for somebody who's on the front
lines to have somebody at home
to write to on a regular basis i don't
care how many letters you got
wasn't enough when i'd read her letters
i just felt strong all over again
shelley convinced bernard to publish the
letters in a book
dedicated to those who didn't make it
back home
so you learned a lot not only about your
mother's and father's relationship and
how it began but a lot about your father
yes in some way were these kind of love
letters to you
too yes because
we're here and if he hadn't made it
through we wouldn't be here
a treasure trove of long forgotten
letters
telling a family's love story for
generations
to come for cbs this morning chip
reid washington what a beautiful family
picture
did you love everything about mr brown
especially how he grabbed his daughter's
hand when he was talking
oh i love these stories of when somebody
finds a you know a shoe box full of in
this case 600 pages
you know that tells this whole story
that you didn't even know about a family
member really
and you always hear the stories about
the soldiers back then who didn't talk
about their experience that's right
they could write it down but they
couldn't talk about it stuff that their
own family didn't know
and so interesting that it triggered all
those memories in from him as well
such a treasure yeah very nice dear
selma a world war
ii love letter romance is on sale now
and
important to know all proceeds from the
book will be donated to ronald mcdonald
house
bernard says that his daughter shelly
was actually hospitalized for months as
a young child
and with the money from this book he
hopes to help other families
in that very same position